Monday Monday and I got a couple things
to say Monday know I got energy was
Friday or worst podcast it was probably
had the lowest energy of volt I had the
lowest energy and I'm not so big time me
I play back from hanging out of all the
celebs and he came here like I did I did
a little studio I I did I hang I hang
with a-listers now and I apologize for
that but I'm gonna find I'm gonna find
some time for you thanks man I want to
apologize I want to apologize to you and
our listeners I told the goats story
it's the same time stole that story line
it's the second time I've told the ghost
story I know that I knew I don't want to
remind you cuz I feel bad now cuz do you
think maybe he's seen out oh my god I
knew but I figured there was enough time
that fast and I guess I guess I have an
apology because I didn't tell the real
goat story you can tell another goat I
didn't tell the story I you didn't
finish it it's 32 it's such it I know
but the problem is the real story of the
goat it's not a good story dude
it's not a good story you know I you're
about to go on the school I'm not gonna
tell the story I'm just gonna say that I
mean if you want to hear the real story
I know it I know that it's a long story
but I'm just saying I feel like what I
live that day off there I left out just
the one part where the goat bit me well
I know the go was giving birth and I
know a little bit about birthing animals
I don't know if you know that but my
father is from Wisconsin so I would
spend my my summers on the farm okay and
and so when it comes to delivering calf
Pig goat I know what I'm doing okay and
I didn't tell that part cuz when I tried
to assist the goat with its baby go turn
around and bit me okay okay okay
and the goat bit meet with his flat
grass stained teeth ooh that hurts it
hurts like a [ __ ] gotta go they
got dull grass chopping teeth I prefer
him to be sure and I'm a good guy but
I'm [ __ ] I don't like darkness would
you do well the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
I had I had the half the baby in my hand
hold on to me just because this is a
continuation of the original goat story
look here can I let me just show you
here just okay you're the go
okay let me just go say you're the goat
and so just kind of move so I'm I'm here
and I'm trying I'm trying to get the
goat baby baby baby punch I punched the
goat in the Fate home but the goat whips
around and bites me like this go fit me
on my face now you know but the baby
goat is here and I go I grabbed the baby
because I go hey and then wait hard and
then I take a [ __ ] rock no you call
it baby go do you know look up what they
call it baby go stay there pause in the
story the [ __ ] up red tsunami nope what
are you called there you go you want to
say it yeah Billy kid Billy Billy I kid
I kid
but there can only be one kid right
brother yeah so kill them [ __ ] from
Raqqa - miss braids you cry and that was
the day I got fired from a TV but I
became a Satan
so I gotta see although oh sorry dude
that's the real ghost story
oh yeah so that's the real goat story
dude thank you for playing goat yes that
was a good guys
and scene was a good dying go thank you
sir so that's way better yeah but people
get mad when you kill a baby goat in
front of its mom and then you kill the
goat mistake balls you leave the kid
they call it baby goat they call a baby
Kota kid why so when you eat baby goat
when when you see a restaurant they go
we've got a special as a kid is kid and
I go well there's only one kid and I'm
not missing any me yeah you can't have
two kids that can be only one and kill
all dotes if you see them so how the
baby goat sir you know you call it baby
go do kid they are a cute they're
adorable
I felt bad stories way better I felt bad
- bully reining yourself don't ever take
my back like that again saw what I do
yeah did you see my protection though
very good no I was trying to have you
bite my faith you know what your teeth
are like dole slippery teeth because you
have been his Alize doesn't really hurt
I know yeah but I'm getting there is no
intently slaughtered liver lips on my
face again couple things to know ten
weeks
Oh Bry gonna have two things going on
with them
one straight teeth all right no you are
not having who told you those are gonna
be straight and ten well you're gonna be
straight in ten weeks right now and I'll
tell you this though you can seek with
Invisalign it is my psoriasis it'll be
gone y-you mean the figured out what the
[ __ ] the problem was can't eat
nightshade vegetables candy blueberries
can eight feet long and you can't eat
artichokes because they have what's
called nitrates all Moline in it and
that's what's giving you yes all right
so yeah I just found out for anybody who
has psoriasis it's kind of [ __ ] nuts
it's called solanine which is in
blueberries oh so you know those in your
oatmeal so I talked to this doctor he
goes he's risest he does yes he goes
well so willing you're taking you eating
nightshades I go wouldn't he goes
tomatoes potatoes bell peppers eggplant
okra
blueberries potato stuff lubbers that's
holy
that's what about the come you guzzled
as long as the guy has naughty what does
God say about you swung [ __ ] as long as
the guy's not eating in ninety-eight
vegetables here's one
good then we're good but that day that
day he goes he goes like this he goes no
peppers no tomatoes no artichoke no
tomato blueberries no potatoes I swear
to god those are tough for you well that
day I had had I put about a pound of
blueberries in my shake I then had
artichokes on my fish that's what I then
had at Via Veneto I had artichokes um I
had a vision I then had a tomato salad
and I had peppers and I had two potatoes
my skin was like what and since you've
been doing it better than that it's
literally like my we're gonna do for
your teeth though the stress is I've
just told you dude no you're [ __ ]
full of [ __ ] if that you think I'm busy
lines working bro
I'm telling you right now mmm tell me
right now
I'm gonna be fine I think it'd be fun
you ain't wait you starts you in August
yeah that's the goal get them straight
teeth by August right yeah can't have
crooked teeth EF dude you know what I
went on a hike isten meant Manville
Canyon man Mandeville beautiful what the
[ __ ] eautiful what in the world are ya
dude Ryan you need to move there yes we
do but you have to have a well people do
you know that they ride their horses to
school and Channing Tatum yeah you gotta
have this small Channing yeah he's every
bit of 6/1 you know why I went 100
pounds you know I went there little man
big in 61 yes
you know who I went with was Wes Wes
yeah we went there and not brought my
son than the next day but it's gorgeous
up there it's gorgeous that's where you
want to live it's yes that's that house
and trulia there when I say not give
them away I mean like oh no you talk
about you start like Trump would be like
you Trump with after like starting a 4.5
million for nothing
yeah no I know four point five now
that's that's lower no there's nothing
there there's nothing like five no and
that crazy there's nothing there no now
you got it my house is off Rick dick it
is the thing is it's close yeah it's
like four miles away from me and Wes
like oh we're gonna go there and I'm
like dude there's no heels up there we
pull it I'm like what the [ __ ] it was
gorgeous man it's it's it's all right in
your house there
yeah maybe neighbors there yeah I'd love
that I'd love that
and we'll be the same we won't be any
happier I don't know you have that view
I know you get you standing I did a
podcast with Bert Kreischer on Friday
I'm not sure when he releases about how
I'm never happy and how he isn't either
that's that's there that's that's the
human condition always wanting going
from one to one but I'm obsessed now at
51 with the idea that there's a way out
of that yeah you'd be wrong oh yeah yeah
oh yeah oh yeah he's Garry Shandling
meditated a day for said damn life
the happy as a clam here who else you
want to go with Conan O'Brien [ __ ]
happy man
why is Conan not a talks about it not
just like you know like everyone thinks
he thought his dream job was gonna be oh
saying it's a dream job because
sometimes it's a [ __ ] night of course
it is it and I don't want to do it of
course you know it's always you know
what you want think when you finally get
it I'm sorry but there are this you know
this and everybody knows this that
that's saying finally the hottest girl
in a while finding you guys tired of
[ __ ] her there there are women that
are just you're like wow you're
incredible and I don't want to bang well
it's weird it's like that when you find
out what celebrities was like he cheated
on her and P Reich what how could you
cheat on put whatever girl you want and
then that's I think some guys I know
yeah makes sense yeah not that you
wouldn't want to hook up with a girl or
that you get the house sure if you
listen I love human beings but every
goddamn morning yeah how many switch it
up that's right I love humans they get
used to everything everything you get
[ __ ] used to everything I don't think
it's a problem not being contestable
that first more ever um you know I was
you know there's a it's driving me nuts
but people get so into the Royal Wedding
I'm you I'm sure you watch much TV but
you're [ __ ] familiar with the Royal
Wedding yes my boy Prince and he got
married to the LA girl writes like a
successful [ __ ] love story what's
crazy to me is when I was watching some
of that royal wedding in Will Farrell
did HBO where they flew him in he did
like a live thing like use this
characters hilarious he said basically
making fun of it right
and so I was watching it and with Harry
and his brother said what's his
brother's name chopped off saying it's
Harry
William brother William when when I look
at their hair and their hair it's
[ __ ] with Wheeling's is gone your boy
here he's is super loose on Thomas it is
five flat counts [ __ ] because those guys
have all the money in the world that if
all the resources yeah and they just
rock it they rose nothing can do now
what are you gonna do just take propecia
now why don't they do I ran out of
production why don't they do it I think
that sometimes propecia works for some
people and other people but they want
you to do the Piven round yeah get their
tuition is legit yeah unless you're
gonna go bald like William just go bald
bro yeah get the egg nest on the side
cobalt Oh looks like [ __ ] I know and
then with Harry's a dime piece he has
that his daddy Harry's a stud but he is
I know I'm Jonah I saw they were talking
about I noticed and I thought bro if his
is light on top like that but he but he
everybody just go on your propecia man
look at the president that propecia it
makes your dicks off it's not true no
ask Ellen so she did yes cut a diamond
right now okay all ultimate ultimate
comes a good-looking guy when he's
younger with the hair oh I know I'm on
it looks just like his papa though yeah
but his Papa's here is actually pretty
legit yeah but now she's dead what's MEA
describing it's that's a that's a rough
way to lose your hair right yeah I guess
are you sure you a king you know tied
and you don't give a [ __ ] I guess so I
still would I'll tell you I won't invite
to my wedding not that he would come in
any facet David Beckham don't invite
that timepiece that steel hit the [ __ ]
show he does oh he comes on the red
carpet and just I mean you're like his
wife dresses him no you got to see him
bring up David back at the Royal Wedding
oh hey man hey bro you don't steal the
line like you learned like I saw Mark
Levine glint looks like a sparkling ball
dude he mates
Prince Harry look like a [ __ ]
underwater eel yeah look at this what
are we doing come on bro that's the real
Prince of England
some guy look at that out look at that
look at that dapper that dapper outfit
its curl his girl gotta get she's super
basic but you have to dress like that if
she's not who made him like that she's
the one who [ __ ] he's a stylish dude
man he created a whole business around
that look at that look at the business
around look at that [ __ ] look at the
fresh shade here and and the people that
I know who know Beckham he's a rich dude
he's a regular
you see when his son surprised him at a
restaurant I started crying no that's
adorable
yeah his son goes he's like somewhere
eating a sudden didn't see his son like
a month and his son goes hey dad he's
filming just starts crying let me see
that he hugs him from the back have you
have you heard me see have you when they
asked him to go on the road and do this
stuff he goes I get physically ill
leaving my children ah
he's awesome he's such a [ __ ] good
guy it's so true
that's such a dime piece I bet they have
open relationship I don't think so I
think so I think he make we go great
[ __ ] football he was kissing him for
a long time what a good dude which is a
military kid
I'll two sons birthday oh that's back
it's David's birthday I know what this
is like I love my son like that I love
my son just like that - I hate loving
something not much I hate it that's good
it's seriously so you're so vulnerable
dude you're [ __ ] and you love Lisa but
don't invite David Beckham to your
wedding see that I do that to my son
right there I'll be doing that to my son
when he's 19 I'm just gonna have uh Glee
groomsmen it's wrong with you bro look
at how great that is that this guy loves
his kids that much are you kidding I
love this dude well actually not like
David Beckham I God first team all die
piece ever he's up there
my friend my friend doesn't talk to his
dad and his dad came to my show and I
knew his dad when I was in college and
you know sons now my age and you know
what he said to me his father said [ __ ]
that he's probably not was father a [ __ ]
no nope nope no yes
he goes I know you worship goats and
your Satanist and then he hugged me yeah
and then we slew goats - can say I
always thought you of you as my son no
you know that other guy I mean Jerry
your son yeah [ __ ] that no he well good
to see you he was an impossible man and
my friend just one day said I can't be
with around you anymore you're a toxic
person and they hadn't even talked in 20
years but when he saw me it came to my
show and he looked at me and he said
love your kids Brian love your kids and
I was like yeah and I looked at their
regret oh my god I don't want that out I
looked again I went no [ __ ] yeah right
no she should have your the
brain-busters yes'm sometimes family
dynamic man right yeah especially pride
play big French champion family but just
because you're family doesn't mean you
get along I told you that sometimes at
us people get along with look at Cheney
murdered his entire family right here in
a freeze right now he's little happy
life ever slow he because yeah because
Santa as days he feasts on them he took
their bank accounts and he bought a
place in downtown them and when you eat
their heart you are also a Satan and you
become one with your family I'm fine
with you if you want some chin family
soup the snow you shape it out that's
right one
he will ship it out if you want exactly
god man I thought of you last night - I
met detective I was
jacking off no I'm just kidding I was
jacking it hard no I was watching my dad
stop you there because I want to hit the
story but my mother one time I used to
like when I was young I was like eleven
twelve and I'd be like this and I just
took a little bit under the table and my
mother like Brian it's not appropriate
my friends because it was my mother my
dad comes home and you know he's jacking
off he's jacking off in front of in
front of me with his friends there and I
don't think it's appropriate my father
goes you're jacking off and she goes no
II do it in the air
my father just looking a go sorry yeah
that would be horrible don't jack off
and God don't mimic Jack daughter story
escolares so we knew you're gonna be a
problem child mics don't start jacking
off in the air I'm Farrah it's lapis I
was air jacking that's so strange
it was new I thought it was had my
friends died because I would get deep
into it I get my tongue out and it was
just a way to ruin everything
not good no I was watching the Billboard
Music Awards we were great hosted by
Kelly Clarkson she killed it but they
named any big star Bruno Mars Pharrell
Kendrick Lamar post Malone name Amy big
star you want any star when they showed
BTS the Orion pop hip-hop group
I'm Tony even Carson's I shoot safe just
and BTS come up later and the [ __ ]
place would just go cool why because I
was through the Regas I was not familiar
with them their show even Kelly Clarkson
on twit headphones on she goes and next
stop and she was get ready a pair of
these guys have a few fans you should
put headphones on she was BTS and they
showed girls crying oh this is the
Korean girls writer I'm sure he can find
it chin pretty much anyone they're just
you it was a lot of services a lot of
Korean fans but there's also like
there's some k-pop is no joke
did you see American like there was a
story on any was radio lab where kpop
were one of the girls one of the girls
was she had done a one of the boy the
boy had done something or one of the
girls who done something that was in
Korean culture considered to be he
didn't treat her well he wasn't
gentleman or he was kind of being scummy
and when they had all the different
bands and their fans would be in the
stadium and they would like they'd be in
you know you know they'd sort of cheer
yeah like teams and when they came on
that section totally silent totally
[ __ ] silent then there was a tabloid
magazine that showed pictures of a kpop
star because her ex-boyfriend sold them
to this tablet right the in all of Korea
shunned that magazine and didn't I I
really appreciated to as it got about
yeah oh you want it you want to do what
Americans do oh really you want to shame
a woman not up he's your boyfriend [ __ ]
you and that guy had that like changes
maybe he's here now he's my friend well
I paid 399 for those pictures and
they're really good right um but this
the BTS in everyone was on that stage
literally I mean in the crowd they get
crazy but for these guys I was like what
the [ __ ] is going on I'd never see ya
guys click on the BTS fake love top one
which is the most views everybody thinks
this is 5.1 million views my point 1
million and one speaks legit English
well they know they go to school at the
age of like 6 and their dance I'm not
mad the song them either they've been
doing like you came on the blog forever
the way a header yeah and I just want to
show the crowd and and there's there's
more plastic surgery there's much less
surgery in Korea than apparently
anywhere else but also the crowd even
like regular white people and black
people look look at they know though all
the words Wow in Korean what is it
Korean or Japanese Korean Korean pin wow
this is awesome
those guys don't [ __ ] with Koreans do
not [ __ ] with Koreans dude when they
want to start dancing they go to school
for this and they don't they train all
day they don't [ __ ] have girlfriends
they don't go party moto I was miserable
you got about a while ago together we're
talking about Vice did a the thing on
the background of kpop my god they they
can't do [ __ ]
you have a girlfriend my grown one down
whatever if you want a boyfriend yeah
who you gonna date on contract right oh
my do you ever only own everything yeah
they don't mean make that good of money
no they give them like a small salary
but they make you super famous some of
the recent one that won't just commit
suicide if you have quite a few yeah
it's like so rigorous and they're just
so much pressure I'm not mad how go to
their YouTube page to look at all these
those show the background that the
entire crowd in the background is are
there for the area is you know the
courious is the largest they're a huge
export of theirs is is pop culture all
of Asia gets their movie how many huge
in their music from Korea millions and
millions but up for three days seventy
million views yeah South Korea about
twenty years ago decided they were gonna
be the emeriti they're gonna be to Asia
what America is to Europe 381 weren't
there pop culture which which is the
biggest one chin that's got to be our
DNA click on that do you know the song
no but I will now did I my last job I
had to listen to it every single day why
I was introducing the show that did like
did these things like culture Korean pop
music what is this no they the biggest
band of all time
they're not the biggest but they're very
all of them are huge though all the big
artisans are all doing the thing yeah
they're cute kid huge cuz it's all like
super catchy music it's happy the dance
moves are like really catchy too so it's
it's just you're so engaged into it look
at this they're good-looking women I
think guys very feminine they get a lot
of plastic surgery right Jim yeah open
they are wider
we're on bye sir how much it's in the
contract you pass they talk about to do
good voices speaking of their crew
singing in Korean mm-hmm they do a lot
of English stuff too you don't a spin
around you know say Korean for me Korea
it is kind of nice isn't it they use
algorithms to listen to it chin I talked
inoculated right yeah like the the
Koreans know what what people like you
know what surgery I don't know this is
tough is it tough or is it awesome Bryan
you know what [ __ ] you hey bro you're
getting into this dude you're getting
into this
oh it's young girls bro bro those are
men that is a man I'm saying young girls
like that's a man bin I'm just saying
they're not my type
there's really no American just don't
get arrested in America like it's go to
jail looking like that this is gonna be
an issue behind Korea they're gonna be a
[ __ ] all right they can dance though
look at how we in sync they are well
yeah they do it they get four hours of
sleep right they make them do this
non-stop sure it's very true yes sleep
for a Korean is man tell they're not
having that much fun they thought they
wanted this well the amount amazing you
know they forced you dye your hair
[ __ ] mint green in the other New York
and you'll do lucky that's the spirit I
know they're very very feminine but
girls love them what crazy [ __ ] no no
love them like they love [ __ ]
Pinkberry who wants to [ __ ] a young girl
of them they like heartthrob and all
that no they're not heart throbs oh my
god they are there's more like best
friends huh yeah yeah just like NSYNC
besides [ __ ] JT no one's trying to
[ __ ] them believe well there are a lot
of guys that are trying to bang the
exact Monica and there are a lot of
girls who are young who are trying to
make I don't know you know a lot of
girls like yeah this is Tina Bob right I
mean yeah it's all girls they're all my
daughter like 10 year olds they're fans
are actually young girls and older one
yes older women at home you know
Backstreet Boys is back on tour they're
selling out their new single I heard the
other day drive down sunset I thought I
was like dude bad
what is that Justin Timberlake sold
no-ho-ho [ __ ] you bro cool I'm sorry I
was in the middle of this I was already
told to listen about you know but
everyone knows JT
Justin Timberlake came from NSYNC and
saying mouth sorry bruh
let me hear bang smoke without their new
song oh they don't break my break in my
heart yo your age Brian look at these
guys
dude you tell me this in a catchy song
chin they hit them focused to man they
still got it yeah come on come on come
on when Nick Lachey and the little
blonde one about the fight doing the
damn good there he is
I know him work with hip nice guy no not
Nikolas a what say Nick Carter uh yeah
who's Nick Carter's older yeah Aaron
Carter's younger brother yeah singing
all right y'all [ __ ] gay and he can't he
used to be the main singing one the
little blonde one he's the best singer
not anymore he lost his vocal chords bro
bro
oh alright like that looks like Bryan
Callen longer wait what's his name no
that's AJ see I think they should get
rid of that dance moves because they're
too old for it and that makes it awkward
probably but that one with the long hair
you looks like a cartoon kid he looks
like the sign that live skit I'll say
him pleat it a little old to be dressed
that way but it's all good not really
good voices though man dude yeah they
were major hits made they never never
even stops that never stops singing
either well they did take a long time
off cuz he got [ __ ] by their manager
and they took a long time off he had a
drug problem
yeah that one had a hard drug problem
lock problem boy yeah sucking dick and
store cocaine Oh took some time off he
game in no but that's my theory
okay you're spreading rumors right now
hmm now the guy with the hair I'm the
Chris Lea look hello Chris do with
crystal ear with mustache more muscular
crystal eeeh who I don't he looks like a
magician he looks like he's like if you
cast a magician I would be like dude
you're too mature to magician
you're too magician now you got to make
up your mind you want to be d'Artagnan
do you want to carry a sword and be
Spanish do you all look like graden from
Mortal Kombat what are we doing at cuz
I'm getting a magician karate
yeah there's a lot of there's a video
game kind of like character you you [ __ ]
dudes do you not get confused well it
just looks like he pulls bunnies from a
hat and it makes Tigers disappear then
sings its songs any hits yeah but got me
started all that kpop in but I heard
this down the street and I was like do
backstreet stop there this is my jam but
you know what it's my now they're making
Bank is they probably are smart and now
they're renegotiating their culture now
they probably own a lot of it yeah but
also they did they did a because I love
country music no fact for your ass
from Denver obviously but Backstreet
Boys have a country song there are
featured on a country song I've heard
that one Jim god dammit you too dude I'm
sorry bro I'm a country on pop culture
good night you know I never see you
anymore cuz you're at home in front of
that TV work you're at home in front of
that movie not Oh cut that money no
you're right I know man I don't would
not you watched a lot of T Oh withdraw
order Georgia line chin up Johnny hit it
borderline function DJ chin [ __ ] up - OH
muscles oh that's Lord Georgia line man
huh I can't hear it
you got turn up believe me it's up all
this them dedicated to the girls
so this is all this is them in florid
lines this [ __ ] is the hotness Jen I'm
[ __ ] sick of educating [ __ ] on what
school this could be you chin but you're
you [ __ ] around bro I know already a
good song never wanna run empty well
they show the one that [ __ ] dudes and
kiss my do that [ __ ] to my white with
cameras
my wife would roll her freaked out she
be like ah God
meanwhile Nick Carter's solo as [ __ ] sad
or no he's oh he made that one girl
there's a show on vh1 married yeah
that's her they had their own show you
know whose brother is transsexual yeah
Aaron Carter came out went I like dudes
ain't girls okay alright bisexual what I
call it transsexual yeah you're right
chin I don't know why know all this
stuff Brian alright congratulations
thanks bro that's awesome alright well I
don't know how we got started on that
kick at all is wait wait let me ask you
on this fan before we get into it over
this pin what's the most romantic thing
have you ever done romantic see you're
like me I know that's what happens like
like like you know Valentine's Day
birthday have you done anything really
special with a bunch of roses I love to
cut the pause I feel like I'm the gift
that keeps on giving
I'm the guy that do you know I'm cool
year-round yeah you don't sin
I'll need your made-up holiday I'll need
Hallmark's made-up Valentine's Day I'm
just not saying I'm not going to either
I ain't good with it like Mother's Day
yeah yeah well I got kids celebrating
365 yeah no I better get a cool gift of
dope pair of kicks on Father's Day right
you got a wet my beak a little bit of
ice if you're happy her year otherwise
you're gonna you can sulk dad of the
year do something yeah do something yeah
I don't know man I'm not going it for my
son on make holidays I make them a big
deal but for when you adult we adults we
adult I agree
we Dalton we don't we Dalton you don't
think we don't need to wait I
interrupted you I wanted to hear your
next story I'm sorry Serena Williams has
the documents on HBO yes
you know she won the one of the big
masters was tennis you know tennis yeah
Grand Slam
she won or whatever giant [ __ ] Master
Elton when she was eight weeks pregnant
and they filmed that no one she was
pregnant going into that it's not son
she would they go through that hurt so
you know she's married to the guy who
started reddit he's a billionaire
now when I say white if there's a
spectrum of light he's Armenian well no
he's white white hmm is that me man he's
a white boy so you might have Armenian
incision ancestors yeah however he's is
white and nerdy and he's white white
nerdy he's white wait nerdy the the so
she was born raised in Compton Yeah
right
beautiful african-american lady born in
Compton right yeah meets up with this
nerdy reddit dude and they get together
it's a very unlikely match oh and even
she her sister goes we had no idea like
and Serena does I'm not a commitment
type of person but it was just there for
the reason it's so interest you got food
of thought this white nerd Basie she was
this white and nerdy dude and me would
hit it off and she was and then would
have thought that's unbelievable and she
could see what I thought we got pregnant
so this is the best part so they live in
Florida right and her again she's from
Compton right yeah and her family's over
and they're cooking fruit and he's like
he just doesn't fit you can just tell
it's like a weird vibe yeah it's fun to
watch and their kid is cute as [ __ ] but
that is kind of amazing right like he's
really cool right she's a she's she is a
such an athlete greatest tennis player
ever best female tennis player ever see
and I found the best syrup I said this
last night I said to me she's the best
female athlete ever that's that's a
legit thing to say man I I'm actually
I've seen her improve right with you
I've seen his person when when choose
woman ah pause but yeah to certain tell
he's our lineup the same manager yeah
and they had me come to the Miami open
or if she was in yeah and I was back in
her dressing room and she's one of I
thought I've seen a lot of athletes in
my lifetime I just went oh Mike oh yeah
you see the arms and they get legs and
the ass on her story she moves and I
think she's super sexy to you to light
now all all respect to okay
see lighting yes I'd say you're not even
the [ __ ] ballpark sir I don't like the
way you're talking to me but I do agree
with you I don't gain ain't even on guys
who's she dating before she dated read a
common when she team con comment you're
right now here's no now he'll spit some
lyrics in here and [ __ ] your problems
but what's my boy what's my boys name
Alexis Ohanian okay so Alexis Ohanian
Armenian name I'm gonna make really look
like easy yeah make a call right now
call right tiny do no the opposite
I'm telling you with a guy with who
wants to step to Sarina
he knows who's been wrong and I believe
he's got a [ __ ] hog a cannon you
think he has data it's got a billion
dollars in Han and 100 percent see I
don't think he has a Kayla I think he
has a small and I don't know a smart guy
had a long conversation with him about
an hour no he's smart guy ridicu smart
smart funny because they asked they
asked him they go you know you cuz they
were going to some party for Sarina and
they go you just go to parties he goes
oh no Isis actually won the first prize
I'm invited to he was the only parties I
know when I was in college my friends
have parties and by parties I mean we'd
all get our super computers and connect
them in the same room we talk to each
other yeah I like him I think he's I it
is such an unlikely match like it like
it the way I look at it and is if he can
get her I'm just saying physically then
I can get her she'd like me you know her
know so this is so he billionaire he's
billionaires a billionaire right so he
could buy your show so and also
intelligent but what does she find a
tractor because she's but she could go
live in I think it's yeah I agree I
think it's the yin yang thing okay same
way Breanna was dating and I love she
still is the billionaire from Dubai or
whatever it's the yin yang thing where
with billionaires and a white
billionaire like this
she's been down that other road maybe it
just hasn't worked out yeah well there
but she dated LaVon what was it
Harrington not her was that the older
one no I was her Lavar here yeah you
ever seen that man from an end State
beat beat everyone up in here that's
right he's simply a son that's right
he was so scary when he played for yeah
I mean I mean I mean that's not him that
I am who is that basic dude that's a
basic guy but I appreciate that she
dates basic cuz I'm basic so I
appreciate you're not baby I need it I
need to get I mean I need to get a
couple shots of her in a bikini
like right there take a look at her body
there you're talking about cuz when I I
stood there and I spoke to her
no I'm can you back up yeah go back up
please she's very right there right
there to the left chin the yeah there
you go now now take a minute look at the
ABS you're talking about a hole when I
was I was standing in a group talking
her and I just kept looking at her arms
and her back I bet you're so annoying
well yeah I actually reached over and
grabbed her arm at one point I just
coming do you know what you're like with
her yesterday I was hiking there's these
gnats and I was like this that thing
what she does to you get out if she
matted me away she's mad at me
no she goes I'm attracted to you and I
was like I can't marry you cuz I'm busy
and she goes all right we'll keep me in
mind
I I feel like she sucked like those
those super winners like Serena Williams
there's they're so alpha on the women's
spectrum there's so alpha you're gonna
need a dude who's gonna take a back seat
you need it otherwise you can have some
Siamese fish now there's levar Hansen
he's he's not a small man hmm
it's interesting it is very interesting
to me it's it's a watch on HBO it's a
four-part series it's interesting
so you think because she's such an alpha
in such an extreme winter she wants a
civilian it's the kind of like there's
so much fire out she needs a little not
execu civilian his ability but she needs
someone who's not in the same Lane okay
yeah you can only hire too much you're
like that well you can only have one and
I free it I think I made George Carlton
said you'd only have one headshot in the
household to headshot style that's
always what I've said that's what Rogan
said Rogan that came famous from George
Carlton okay George Carlin yeah Rogan
Rogan said that to me a long time ago I
was dating an actress again it wasn't
working out and he goes you've got it
you gotta just gotta have a no headshots
policy you just can't have it's not
gonna work out I'm not sick in the same
effort
yes that was when my life got easier now
I'm not saying you need a cheerleader
and they can't have their own job in
their own career and stuff like that I'm
not saying that I'm saying when you're
both entertainment the selfishness it
takes if both of you are like that your
kids are gonna suffer something like
that it's also the fact that you're
you're always gone if you're successful
you're but that's why I'm saying though
this selfishness of the
gone so there has to be some sort of
normalcy yes I don't I don't see it ever
worked out people that do
I would imagine behind closed doors it's
pretty [ __ ] up I don't actually have
there seriously and some people make it
happen like like but they're not present
they make it happen their roommates
you haven't make it happen tough it's
very tough it's very tough no you get
kids involved telling a different animal
man animal different animal you're just
gone but uh yeah Serena Williams beasts
super attractive right oh yes I mean
she's a she's a special human being
she and her sister and there's a
documentary on her father who doesn't
get enough credit her father who
basically was just relentless and
turning them into complete champions and
because they way it was a tire and stuff
he created not only to great champions
but to black women who are an example
for so many people who came out of like
you know an area yeah but office
remember it was like I'm gonna make you
guys remember also an area that no one's
playing tennis and he watched you know
you just watch was flipping to chess
I'll tell that I bet my kids good is
that right yeah he has no bad guy I
admire that very odd that my kids could
do that he doesn't get enough credit
you know another of him as dad or Mike
Jackson's yeah him as a dad really my
dad did some [ __ ] so I promise you Janet
Jackson no it's true she's just one
award last night look at Michael Jackson
biggest pop singer of all time
he killed dive Justin five tired fifty
killed himself or whatever happened Lily
fell asleep soon well you know he's on a
lot of drugs III think that kind of a
dad is different than her dad they these
women seem very well-adjusted and and
and extreme learners but have a life and
know how to have a life and know how to
keep it in perspective and can you
imagine having a dad like that and not
like Andre Agassi's father was on the
Olympic irani an Olympic boxing team or
maybe their I mean the kickboxing team
and his dad was a [ __ ] tyrant if you
read his autobiography which is
incredible I think it's called life or
something and he was just an absolute
but he turned Andre Agassi and it will
complete champion dude how about on
there's a show on TLC called
in the transition its upgrade for this
it's about four older married couples
and want enough the husbands in each
thing want to put through the Caitlyn
Jenner they want to go to yeah
that's a very strange way I feel like
and I want you to however you feel I
want you to turn into what you want to
be I don't give a [ __ ] it doesn't bother
me in one aspect do I do what you want
to whatever should make you happy my
thing is is is it a new thing dude
III just for me like I can't even do TR
t like people like get a little on a
little testosterone I'm like I'm 51 you
know I'll do it when I when I literally
can't get my dick hard or I'm just too
tired or whatever but I just any any
little detail any even go and get a
checkup was a lot somebody want to check
up you oh I have to for my stuff yeah
you know I'm saying like like but then
to go here yeah I mean we're gonna do
we're gonna turn you into a woman
what is that abuts really going on
matching cutting you dick off now
Caitlyn Pitt that apparently she did
yeah it's the word on the street she
went full she now has a front hole full
Quito really no yeah wow I don't know
man that is a because you you have to
know as a man I saw a large woman who
used to be a man clearly the shoulders
the hands just the the the skull
fraudulent pair this was this was a man
your size who said I feel like a woman
and decided to go out go for it and it
was just an unfortunate it was an
unfortunate so I do some diet changes to
if you want to fit the profile right
this guy was just this is this personal
fool nobody this person was just a giant
and decided I it's like I might joke
about like Samoans if you're a Samoan
you probably don't want to make the
transition because you're not gonna be
that's a big dude no matter what though
yeah no matter what you do with a lot of
Samoan men I don't care how many you can
pump all the estrogen in there you can
take out a couple ribs you're still
dealing with a [ __ ] massive you try
and I say I say this I'm doing
you know how there's a three-year-old
where their fathers giving them estrogen
to lend them seriously you're a 3 year
old bat's anyways a guy who runs a
network higher than that higher response
3 old says oh I was born a boy but I
feel like a female outrage and I said
well I was just in parameter
transformers and Robocop as a kid yeah
if my dad would let me turn my [ __ ]
arms into robots I would I feel like
when I'm like decent [ __ ] yeah and he
and that should be not allowed horrible
right wait till that child is an adult
hit this trailer though it's crazy
families lost in transition the bummer
for me is when there's kids involved
which there is though these people
probably did feel like women I know
that's the sad part
yeah but then they've been lying to
their partners yeah you got married you
had a kid but sometimes they feel like
they have no options yeah say what the
night that was told me is really blurry
I was sitting in bed and les was sitting
at the computer Evander was asleep I
didn't know how she would react whoa
oh yeah you know by the way I've been
technically lying to you for the past
nine years it's [ __ ] up due to your
mate your rights that she was just gonna
leave me I was terrified thinking that
yeah she would leave you know she's down
as [ __ ] told me that there was
something really important he had to say
and it starts to get kind of fuzzy after
that yeah I told her it's like I am
transgender
I cried a lot Oh your lated nothing he's
not gonna be raised I felt a lot of
different emotions everything from lied
to to understanding to conflicted ya
know she went so I'd beat his ass oh no
this one's whatever listo young there's
a dude they've been married for 30 years
and told his girl good stuff
great how crazy is that it's crazy to me
I mean I don't know is he crazy what if
they really feel I don't know I think
this is my thing I think there's there's
a scaler I think some people actually
suffer from condition where they're born
males or females and feel like the
trapped in the body and then there's
some people you crazy mental and your
crimes they have a Mentalist and but
it's also a way to to a group aunt like
latch on to a group that's getting
attention and they have their mental
sickness and they're looking for
attention yeah I don't know myself I
said more on that I feel like a happy
were born that way
but there's some people like come on
yeah I just think that what mental
illness in many different forms you face
you want attention yes it's in many
different forms and and there are some
people that are that are that might be
due some people I do believe like that
like Kristen Beck who just always felt
like a woman inside always just felt
like a woman Navy SEAL you know but
always felt like that and was trying to
Bruce Jenner and I think a lot of hands
janitor try to kill themselves like that
let's oh my god so when you're when
you're yeah when you're that desperate
and you're stuck inside the body of a
man and you feel like a woman and you
can kill yourself I have to believe that
that emotion is very real about the
beginning probably same thing you think
you but you don't I don't know I I do
what's tricky for me it's tricky but he
has there's such a that was tricky furry
that one's tricky for me
although he had been when if you look at
the initial nose job getting a tiny nose
whose suck look at Bruce Jenner before
he got a nose job
he was about as good-looking as it gets
and
got his nose yeah judging when you're in
that Hollywood spotlight and you're with
just these vultures referred to as the
Kardashians who are gift they all
changing everyone the dynamics around
he's changing look at how handsome he
was before it look at that [ __ ]
like he was getting girls like when
you're that guy you get you don't need
you don't have any worries he's six foot
three but that's good-looking is good
[ __ ] like that I mean but he is he's
a really good-looking very good-looking
but let's how many girls you think he
[ __ ]
what do you don't know I mean again I
don't know what his don't you think of
hundreds
I would imagine a hundred one could have
for sure and then all of a sudden yeah
you're not but you know I'm saying like
why would you do that to your nose what
was wrong with there you're in Hollywood
though you're in Hollywood you that's in
Hollywood that's a Hollywood movie star
lock right there before that he's as
good-looking yeah yeah but but that's
him when he's young he's got an older
Brian and then and then you were the
cortege when he got that when he was
younger he got the nose job when he was
actually really young that's what I'm
saying so I know but his look has
changed over the year yeah but and
remember your entire family have all
gone reconstructive facial surgery and
body surgery
your daughter Kendall or I'm sorry Kylie
has basically been artificially created
in a laughs and you're a witness to this
and you're seeing this and you don't
think that art does bro those bags
we were those one surgery sure that chin
but if they use that to you uni like
this you go yeah whatever bro Lee at
your ears yeah all that stuff yeah but
think but when your dude [ __ ] I think
he ingrained into this but I think it
was there before yeah I think I think
maybe a seed was there before but when
you're there's a lights on you non-stop
and this can change this this is normal
this becomes normal you know and it's
like I take a little bit off the top all
right go ahead go ahead and you can lie
podu lipo Kanye get lipo so there during
this bubble that's not really bizarre
you gonna chop my dick off like we said
when you're when you're getting older
and you're really you've got lots of
money and stuff you do obsess over being
younger immortality you do steroids you
do plastic surgery I see this we see
this all the time in Hollywood people
that we know you see
you're like wow so I don't know man I
don't know why you me Justin get veneers
I don't understand that we would love
because I'm cool because after this
Invisalign in ten weeks dude I'm gonna
be about as good-looking as you know
what you're doing you're [ __ ] up
Invisalign stock because you're gonna do
it you talk about in there and that's
not working I everyone else in your
[ __ ] video just went to the desk he
goes he goes you're a fang on yeah I'm
moving in the right direction to this
[ __ ] my teeth are moving in the
right direction
no I can see from here they're no better
say [ __ ] their bed no they're not no
they're not and you know you're right
behind me with the Invisalign eventually
because I'm looking at your teeth I'm
getting onion veneers bro bro I'm going
veneers and here this problem Chompy
white teeth still sittin ears don't they
do you can tell people are wearing
veneers yeah and they look sick they
don't oh yeah oh you like shiny [ __ ] and
I know you want your teeth to match
those terrible boots that you bought
with the buckle that you never wear
anymore they're sitting in your date now
one month settable the belt those are my
favorite boots don't wear it doesn't
there's also my faves
don't say fav those my days if you were
I wish you weren't as tough as you were
cuz I'd have to take a few days of it
I'd slap your mouth dude I'll tell you
get on TRT I'll get veneers
I'm not I don't need it I don't need trt
I'm finally calming down I'm finally
like all right I'm not I'm finally not
jacking off all day long your your socks
make my testosterone lower you hate me
you hate my luck what's this oh hold on
I just Google TR t before after oh you
ain't get em ma [ __ ] especially this guy
yeah well that's a tough one with Vitor
that's it
that's an interesting look Oh God
got that kick the old jaw by your boy
nails tough one tough one um TRT
yeah I mean I think it why you wouldn't
do it if you're these guys wow what a
difference
and that's when he's younger - I know
but what you expect everyone to hate I
mean imagine it imagine if you were so
he's been fine since he was nine ten
lost 40 now so imagine if you went yeah
that's a shocker
if this aerial I remember I used to be
always looking you know it's I'm so nice
a first time right in peace I'd watch
him and I'd be like what up that's the
body I want and then I see that and I go
wait that's not your real body Erik
Silva yes
that's [ __ ] nuts that's the biggest
transition I've seen cuz he had a butt
tits the whole I could give you a list
of guys that blow your mind
really I never would but yeah give us
bro that's that's really wild chin
what'd you do this weekend I saw a
picture on Instagram no tell me if this
isn't suspect man yeah there's a picture
on Instagram jingoes great time at the
Angels game chin sign the picture I've
been there bring it up bring your bring
your grandma do is great time to answer
game and I don't see chin anywhere now
are you trying to pretend you're on that
dangerous game while you're busy doing
other stuff oh we can we talk for a
second right there until please let's
talk about this then do that alright you
can find me right take a good look I
cannot see chin in that Brian tell me
where chin is he's not there are you the
black man with the shaved head and so
you see him I see the black one of the
shaped head I see a guy with head cocked
but she's far as the one that's gonna be
the most difficult to find in the
picture geez you're not like a picture
oh I see the black guy looks i see Meek
Mill in the back photoshopped uh-huh I
don't see you there my friend where you
look towards the middle area does it
look like probably isn't you're wearing
it's somebody wearing a chin mask who
sent somebody you had a fun time Jim
know about this hold on you know about
the $25,000 masks you can wear that the
Tunku was tell me about no yeah I know
but I have a great story of breath Oh
telling me I know he gave he gave ya
whole ear story true story I tell ya
great story uh-huh masks they have masks
that celebrities let out that you don't
know know they wear a mask that comes
over your head it looks real looks real
for a much disagree on upfront
it's a little shady but if you're
wearing one I don't think it's $25,000
what
yeah it's latex and it fits over your
face and they
they mold it to your face perfectly but
you can look like anybody you won't go
anywhere you want you look like an old
man and yeah they wear and people are
like what it's great it's got to look
freaky though right
um the CIA uses him I know that Wow so
no interesting uh what why were you at
the game chin set this up for it's
because the first time I've seen that
you're doing something besides sing in a
black hallway yeah we do this like
tailgate thing every once in a while me
twice a year who's we means a friends by
the way this picture is just like a few
of us we had 30 over 30 people there 30
of you went to the Angels game yeah
what'd you get what'd you guys do after
nothing to get hammered
we got hammered for sure got hammered
she's one of our friends threw up which
I hate I hate when this happens but one
of our friends threw up in the stands
got sloppy so we just said let's go
oh he grabbed everyone enough VIN number
we're there for when they got like were
there down four runs I think I run then
we left
did you see the dime piece himself of
all people he didn't play that day
[ __ ] and everyone is nasals
wearing jerseys Otani you've seen that
we've talked it's all six five Japanese
yeah great hitter great taken over man
yeah he wasn't there that game
mm-hmm modern-day samurai huh
straight-up
boy suit although straight-up uh yeah
the fight he got Sunday you know it's
Sunday right
I got air until why I don't know enough
about Darren tail but since he'd beat up
my way I've been watching a lot of his
fights um I I say this about him we know
he's a very high-level strike I don't
see a lot of what he's doing that's so
different but my guess is that his
ability to measure distance but he's
also very big better than Wonder Boy
though the measured distance Wonderboys
is amazing the only reason I'm going
with him is to give you this before you
get out I remain my pick I'm below the
belt i'm mateus so Wonder Boy is beaten
his last fight he beat Jorge Masvidal
yes before that right Woodley fights
yeah
he's beat Roy McDonald yeah Johny
Hendricks he's he's amazing and then you
know let me tell you Darren tells be
yeah just cancer oniy I know
but Darren tell
is bigger and dare until pressure height
pressure fighter same height heavier
right a little heavier bigger he'll get
in there 200 pounds he's way bigger yeah
so and he's a pressure fighter my
feeling is that if dare until there
until is gonna get is gonna close that
distance Dom so Stephen Thompson is so
good at those at keeping his distance
kickin you in Constance and Catherine I
think trying to counter a guy as skilled
as there until who is also very good at
that seeing that is gonna be a different
game and when Darren till is in that in
that proximity that closer belongs into
those long kicks are no longer a factor
it's going to be it's gonna be a problem
for for one not I picked in till - yeah
I picked up til I think as I say third
round TKO yeah yeah third I could see go
in the fourth but I think his fight goes
on I think he's I just think he's
chillin big he cuts the ring off and
he's too experienced and as the stuff
not experience does no well Wonder Boy
is very experienced but he's from what I
have read and seen I should say you know
it's not fair he saw when we want to say
experience he's not experienced in
high-level mm a high level I'm amazing
different Wonder Boy has way more
experience
if Wonder Boy was a hell of a wrestler
III would then have a different because
I'd be like oh he's gonna close out we
haven't seen telling the ground we don't
know he gets begs the dip Vegas still
has wonder what is the favorite and
that's that's how it should be
yeah and and there's you know there's
dents on welterweight there's dare until
there's Guzman who just fought right and
then there's Coby Compton there's like
these three young yeah horses yeah I
think Taryn tilt if I had to bet on it
would be the guy put my money on this is
right and so so this is a big fight this
is what I'm so excited about the fight
makes no sense right the fight still
hasn't been there long he'll beat Donald
Cerrone and dance when I didn't know who
he was Don so he's under size 7 year he
beats him and then who and then Darren
tails on ranked and ranking people go oh
he's cool number eight in the world and
then punk number one welterweight in the
world slow the [ __ ] down
yes cuz you're forcing this kid now he
beat him all right
he's number one guy in the world now
he's an out what did the [ __ ] man yeah
bring him up a little so what do you do
yeah what he's four years old right now
five that's very young come on man I
when are we gonna learn you know he
might beat him he very well might does
beat him now we got now we got a rose
namajunas our hands now we got like a
young champion even rose had more time
of course but if we know her first it's
a lot of pressure on till but if he does
be in Liverpool yeah I think they're
doing it because tills so big for the
weight class
he looks so good against Alice Ronnie
and they're like you know what maybe
maybe he is the next young champion
who's there forever maybe if he we're
gonna know aren't we we're gonna know
not you know I even yeah I don't know
hasn't got it hasn't got it was the one
boy again like with with Guzman's
signature win with Kobe come din
signature win
it's Demian Maia those are perfect
matchups for them it's the perfect
matchup for the top five guy with Darren
tilt wonderboy Thompson one boys a
striker kills a striker cowboy Cerrone
striker
these are perfect matches we won't know
he's in oh so like time so they get a
until you get a Woodley until you know
swordy a until you get up Maz Badal
water boys pass those tests either
proven RDA is proven woodleigh's proved
mmm it's so interesting you're saying
the big test for Darren is gonna be when
he fights a guy who can wrestle this is
a big test as one of the ways so goddamn
good and if he passes this obviously
he's better than those other guys as far
as potential but yeah until they stop
giving these guys favorable matchups all
the UFC clearly is hoping to until wins
this Liverpool sure it is made for him
to win yeah but let me ask you this when
you when you see when you see till
sparring's you see him sparring and how
he's knocking out his opponents and
stuff who is that type what is that
about the guy he's smart doesn't look
very good but also it's a young hungry
cut type of thing that's what you do
when you're young you know yeah just
just working guys yeah you'd like to
have a lot of toys to play with keep
doing that I don't know who he's
sparring with either I don't like camp
he's at him I don't what most high level
gyms don't really do that but you know
aka do a lot I watched him fight there's
a Serbian guy
UFC
he had a fight with him and went the
distance yeah and so till wasn't
necessarily in that he wasn't doing what
he did to Dallas Ronnie he was fighting
a bigger guy and he got the best of him
but he won that fight he didn't destroy
the guy the guy was flying a lot of that
though too like those early UFC fights
for him your time when he fought that
Bojan yes yeah a lot of those two is him
getting his legs underneath them and
then getting the confidence when I here
till speak in interviews I believe him
yes I don't believe these other guys
yeah like when when Connor spoke when he
first hit the scene you like a lot of
people I don't like him me super he got
he's brash but we believe them with till
when he speaks I believe him he's not
sitting back coming up with sentences
and cool cat phrases neither was Connor
now you believe when they talk y'all I
[ __ ] and when you believe in yourself
that much it can take you to levels you
weren't expecting because that's what it
takes to get to this level you believe
false sense of being you know
untouchable yes but when you're when you
have the skills of Darren till and you
match that with his ego just calm it's
gonna it's gonna take you places 201
pounds when you step in the eye and he's
okay just a giant advantage for him and
he wholeheartedly thinks he's gonna walk
through wonderboy Thompson oh I like
those odds which is [ __ ] up just
wonder I've trained as Wonder Boy he's a
friend of mine
I saw him recently he's a great dude and
I hate picking right amazing.if Woodley
isn't champion Wonder Boys you're
three-time world champion welterweight
that's right
he's a maze that's right but he's just a
[ __ ] matchup for him yeah and Woody's a
lot smaller than Darren till these guys
are all a lot of wood Lee is stood next
to him many times short man five seven
my Russell's a slaw of course you can
and he has a [ __ ] overhand give you
some problems but but but I will say
this and I always tell you guys this and
whether it's surgery whatever it is when
a guy takes a long layoff from fighting
there's a lot going on there yeah it
might be surgery yeah he has his show on
TMZ sports yeah he's on UFC tonight when
a fighter to switch champion isn't
fighting a lot you got a deal with the
guy and I don't think it's a guy a guy
like Darren till the reason hasn't
gotten fights not that you didn't want
it
you see the fight Tarrant Hills not
going on us tonight
Darren Till's not doing movie you know
you want dentals been driving this
entire time he do bags and [ __ ] dudes
up in the gym and that's scary
oh and he's way bigger than all you guys
and he wants this more yeah he has
certain things going 405 that you
already have he wants that you think he
gives a [ __ ] about the movies right now
no and guys don't realize this everyone
WME or what movie can get me and what TV
set can get me and what all I want to
come and do you're okay you're already
looking in that life after fighting no
you tried what you trying to do is get
free yeah no you fight deer until it is
a fighter and you have to deal with that
when you watch this maan against Maya
did you see something different
did you do you feel like man is you want
to see it was mark Ovington who do you
want oh yeah I would love to see that I
think in it's not the UFC's fault but
having Kamara iseman fight Demian Maia
does Guzman a disservice he moves up in
the rankings but Demian Maia if he can't
get the takedown is a boring [ __ ]
fire it's horrible yeah so then no one's
chomp at the bit to see kumara fight now
which sucks cause he's such a talent
yeah yeah I would love to see Kumar
Guzman versus moths at all but the
training prior sets a little funky they
are I'd love to see Kumar verse dos
anjos Co becoming ter as I see him but
the winner of Coby because there's
similar guys I mean in a way fighting
wrestling wise right yeah yeah I would
swings a little more power that's a
great great fight but you know I kill
off the lines yet why kill out the young
lions don't fight each other yet well
you know you you tweeted about our boy
who got cut from the UFC for not
fighting yeah I mean yeah it's
incredible to me it is in it there's a
whole nother backstory with that kind of
oh yeah I'm talking with you see on this
one after I talk about things I've
talked a little bit about it he used of
get his life together
and I tell you guys this all the time he
took a year off from fighting that is
the biggest red flag as a competitor
like I thought like I told you think
think if you asked you're wrong to you
stand on out taking off from podcast
enough they hear from acting it's any
passion you have if someone goes take a
year off man you're gonna freak the [ __ ]
out and we guys not freaking out there's
something wrong well whatever it is
management very true motivation money
whatever yeah something's going on okay
I'll leave it at that
again again though maybe don't fight
don't put it don't match them against
Frank yeah correct Brent you [ __ ] this
career yeah don't [ __ ] up this
flourishing just yes can you give
somebody a little breathing room
don't take a young Brendan job and put
him against [ __ ] na Nogueira
Nogueira oh and then what and then give
him Ben Rothwell after that yeah what do
you think is gonna happen what do you
think is gonna happen with a guy who is
that many a little problem make one
mistake and he's gonna capitalize on
that's what experience you know the
problem is is they give a young B Shahid
referring to myself third person but
Gonzaga who's that and I'd be an CRO
calm and they give me Krogh up then I'd
be there no we can do this yeah and you
could well - sir extend and but then
you're fighting guys with experience
who'd have tricks who get you thinking
one thing because they know how to do
that and you haven't been there before
what I don't like about the dare until
thing in the entire thing is daring till
with his style in his size at 25 there's
a list I can give you that we can create
a highlight reel knockouts we can build
this Liverpool monster a needle he
becomes this knockout machine so by the
time we build the wonderboy fight that
thing's selling [ __ ] papers why it's
not on a Sunday fight Dana White knows
this doesn't he why don't call it is
fast grab it's a cash grab for them so
it's not even Dana it's probably like
now it's what when a corporation you
know it's Dana it's they have so many
issues yeah I don't you know and and
their ratings are nerve and lower I
think right correct
let me find their transition period but
they gotta make some changes
Wow Wow it's really something when you
can make it to the top of that heap
steep em you know search Daniel Cormier
Robert Whittaker max Holloway cubby
you've never met are you reading the
penalty thing yeah it's just something
else when you get when you I'm looking
at all the monsters and every one of
these weight loss or weight weight
divisions and when you beat everybody
and you're at the top that's incredible
mmm-hmm I mean you say people say tyron
woodley is a boring fighter at times
also he's not he's also a great fighter
made every fighter we would even raisins
we eating I gave him [ __ ] as fights with
one of my top those were grateful I mean
that's how you do that fight
I just give some kind of engine what do
you got all right
let's can we revisit the amy schumer
incident yeah i'm ship for this i got
some so so I got to let me let me say
let me do so all we see is Amy Schumer
interrupts comics set which is normal
which is typical and then you know then
from there then we kind of defended Amy
Schumer yeah Phil ascension yeah well I
guess there's more details saying that
she really did so was a headlining event
for that kid or that guy Brendan
his name's Brendan and so at Caroline's
it was his first headlining event his
family and friends so right this place
is packed to see him do his first hour
ever as a headlining event two of the
comics go on this from my understands
from Legion of skanks shut up the Legion
of skanks hey Jerry big Jay big Jay and
our you're on there yeah and when I
listen to big J naught I told the
situation oh holy [ __ ] me and Brian
we're off because they're saying how big
of a deal was for their partner Brendan
to go on there and a headline his first
time and do his first hour for my
understanding he's five minutes into
doing his first hour at Caroline's for
his family and friends Amy Schumer walks
in those of the man who goes hey I need
to do my monologue correct me if I'm
wrong as chin goes I need to do my
monologue percent out life I know I'm
gonna go up there and the manager goes
he's doing an hour at wait till he's
done he go up she turns around and looks
at him this is from the manager and she
goes I'm [ __ ] Amy Schumer I'm going up
which to me is a huge red flag not live
in reality in a movie bombed so then she
walks goes to the stage and goes hey hey
to the side hey and he go up Brendan
being younger and not dealing with goes
uh panic does okay I would probably do
that and there's a thing right okay Jay
had a great point he goes you know how
peak of a rock star you'd be from it
[ __ ] you you can go after me once I
finish that was the rock star move yeah
to be like now hold up let me finish you
can go after
the Rockstar move yeah so that so that's
where she she [ __ ] up and then sends
him tax after goes hey don't make this a
big deal this can make me look like an
[ __ ] like be cool man all this stuff
which of course are in big J get on
their podcast and read the tax threat
oh boy the Brennan guys just look
aggressive passive you know like he
didn't know what to do which you can't
fault them for that whoo yeah that was
am i right on this channel I have fun to
this I mean the exact quotes are not
like no never ever do that to somebody
and I never have and I don't think Rogan
would never do that I don't know anybody
who is who's established or has been
doing stand-up a long time they would
ever do that bill burr would never do
that
nobody would ever do that I don't know
anybody but this guy's like a that's
weird
he's like a beginning sort of comic
right first headlining things so he
that's how anyone I think in his
position and guys oh you guys are you
guys have been there done that for a
while no Brian has I have if I were you
I could imagine you doing something like
you know cutting oh yeah I can imagine
you doing that what do you know Brendan
would get off probably because you don't
know you'd be like at the Comedy Store I
would assume that the comic store wants
me alive and I'd like now yeah oh [ __ ]
all right
and then after I'd be upset if there
yeah if they came up to like dude Amy
Schumer's came on [ __ ] barcia after
we told not to go out like what the [ __ ]
and not go ham on this podcast and come
after you know I wouldn't be Brendan's
problem is is that he's taking kind of
this this [ __ ] route where he's like
it's all good like I see it more as like
just he's a nice guy and he's just he
was over like at that what do you do
that I agree with them that I agree with
how he was caught off guard like oh [ __ ]
Amy Schumer she's a big deal backed out
and he's also look after the fact he's
learned what has happened but come on
it's [ __ ] just the thing is she
started off as a young comic yeah you
know the grind and by the way can I just
say something about Amy Schumer stand-up
comedy all due respect she's not she's
not great I have many many friends who
are funnier at stand-up than Amy
Amy's Amy's good and Amy has earned her
place and Amy's her movie trainwreck
she's doing great
but it's not like Amy Schumer is a
comic genius I don't I'm I get a kick
out of this there's a comic who's been
doing this so long I just get a kick out
of popularity doesn't mean that you're
really funny I know a lot of women that
I'll put up against Amy Schumer
I'll put their hour up against Amy
Schumer in a heartbeat I can give you a
number of them so it's not like just off
the top like less injures yeah any
coming there are a lot of women that
will hold their own and men way better
so which I don't like to get into this
comparison stuff though cuz it's
everyone's flavor is different but let's
not get let's not also get it twisted
ain't nobody that I know none of none of
your dear friends are here in a [ __ ]
peep out of Amy Schumer we're not it's
not like Oh Amy's getting up we don't I
don't know I'm not watching her when she
gets on stage you understand maybe
because I'm just older I've been around
a lot longer than she has but and I
think Amy knows that I think Amy's also
probably shy don't think she would do
that she should be a little aware of her
place as a comic this is the prom be
don't you think is she's in this bubble
where it's not real that's right you're
not it's not real when you're hanging
out with the girl from [ __ ] that was
the movie the [ __ ] Jennifer Lawrence
it's not real when your neighbors
Jennifer Lawrence and you and Chris Rock
is [ __ ] holding your titty every move
you make and you have all this direction
yeah that's not the real world and we
don't like the Caroline that's the real
world that's that's a that kids trying
to [ __ ] get tickets make a living
being comic but I will say this too just
to defend Amy because I've known her a
little bit but I also know people in
know her a long time but for the most
part Amy Schumer's a good gal for the
most part Amy Schumer is somebody that
people say good things about she's never
been an [ __ ] she's never been so
there's a lot of stuff right now but
this is this is not a good look and this
was a mistake
oh these defines I don't think I mean
like this was a bitch-ass move but I'm
sure there's some criticism for it for
sure so if you're gonna act like that it
was saying you should you know your sign
up for enterprise but it shouldn't ruin
her career I don't think everyone
shouldn't work with her you know I'm
saying I don't think comics should shun
her when she walks into the it was a
selfish it was a selfish move it was a
selfish thoughtless move and when you do
that you get you shouldn't you should
pay a price for it you should be called
especially in the comic grill right when
you big-time people you
and that's the other thing I was gonna
say about comedy is like one of the cool
things about comedy is that it's not
like it's kind of an unspoken rule that
when you're all in the green room and
you got Dilber and you got you got Chris
Rock or you got Joe Rogan or you got all
these people and we're all sitting
around nobody is like when I'm talking
to Sebastian where I'm not talking to
the guy who sells out the beacon 10
times in a row I'm talking to Sebastian
who I've known for a long time and we're
both doing stand-up and it's a great
time and all of us and when you're there
with everybody even though you have been
doing it that long
nobody's going I'm better than you dude
stand out it's a very democratic place
yeah it's a it's a great room and it's a
democratic place and that's the place
where you come and you don't bump people
when you're friend when you're on a show
together I it's you're supportive I
guess nothing any less over but just
don't do that yeah and he's like a I
guess young not young but up-and-coming
so it's like an easy target that's what
makes it look really bad let me mean
looking on the outside yeah I don't
think she could do that against an
established comic that's what I'm saying
she does don't like a guy Brian or like
I don't like a burro Oh God but she
never I'd pay money to see it she would
never do that to him that's the hole
right she wouldn't do that to them but
she would do it this allows bad known so
it's kind of messed up it's like Jerry
Seinfeld came up to me I was doing New
York and he goes is this your thing
I said yeah I goes would you mind if I
got up can I just do a maybe like 10
minutes I got to do Leno tomorrow and I
was like yes you can mr. Seinfeld and
then he hung around and watched some of
my set and told some buddies tell tell
me that I was I was something that's
held Shido yeah that's that's Jerry
Seinfeld all right so if Jerry Seinfeld
behaves that graciously and is that
selfless then you know and people say
Jay Jay so I'm feeling the helium it is
a bit of an [ __ ] right remember when
one character hugging me is what are you
doing don't hug me I don't know you
right yeah but there's there's it's like
baseball there's waist up but he's also
he's also two comics everybody loves
Jerry like Jerry Ford II young comics
he's awesome and people have nothing but
good things to say about him so yeah so
so you know how to behave Eames you know
knows better right she knows better she
just got a little living a bottle to
family she's live in a bubble that's
what they're saying that show - they're
like big-time he was like she's at
movies she doesn't even think that she's
doing anything wrong she's just there
the problem about that's a [ __ ] cop
that's a really big problem I've seen it
I've seen people get bit in the ass port
you and I know pretty famous [ __ ]
people in that top of the heap and it's
I'll tell you this right I'll tell you
this right now if she'll do that to a
comic who's in her comedy family which
he is there's a there's a ecosystem I'd
be willing to bet the way she treats
waiters and servants and uber drivers
probably ain't good either hate to tell
you yeah that's there's a huge tall tale
that when I wrote that book she goes if
you want to know how your man's gonna
treat you when you're dating him take a
look at how he treats the waiter because
he'll be treating you exactly the same
way later on mmm so look at how your man
makes it walks to the waitress or waiter
look at how your man or woman treats
people that there that are waiting on
them a flight attendant whatever and
that's exactly how they're gonna treat
you for it down the line that's a really
this really good advice what else you
got - all right I don't know if this is
any better actually horrible but so
there's a cougar attack in Washington
Seattle and then I know you guys heard a
little bit about the story I don't
Brenda you heard about this hell oh so
there's two friends biking in the woods
and then I guess the Cougar just started
stalking them so they did what they're
supposed to do they jumped off their
bikes and started yelling and then I
guess they're cuckoo approached one of
the people and they slammed their bike
like near it and then it took off so
then they started biking again the
Cougar attacked one person and the
person that they attacked the other
person just took off ran away and then
that's the person probably got so as
soon as that person got attacked and the
other person took off the Cougar let go
of the person they attacked and went
after the one that took off and killed
that person whoa yeah Wow so the one
that was failing on their buddy
you actually doesn't do is run my
problem is is if
of a [ __ ] move the guy who died kind of
a [ __ ] move right and so if you and I
are mountain biking let's say that
[ __ ] what Canyon Medela Canyon what's
gone yeah and a [ __ ] mountain lion
start attacking you I'm like oh we had
help I'll call the police and run to
service no or I can spike the [ __ ]
that thing on the head what about this
so what if that person didn't think
there was anything they could do against
a lion oh you don't know I never do
sometimes like so if it was a bear and
it was attacking you of grizzly bear I'm
running away I'm not no you know why cuz
you can't do anything against a Quisling
bear like you know what you could do at
least take your bike throw it on so he
looks up so your buddy has a room to get
away
I will swear to god you I would not run
away can you imagine how you'd feel I
would never talk to first again will not
even be dead I don't say that I survived
though say like we both survived and
that fire found out my friends cook-off
I'd be like ah this time I attacked by a
mountain line you ran away like yep hope
you'll call help what about me man
yeah two against one I do think though
some people get so overwhelmed with fear
cuz it's a wild animal that they they
just panic we call that you know what we
call it where I'm friends called panic
[ __ ] I'm telling I don't have a
friend who would run I do not have a
friend in my circle who would run it
does show you how much that person cares
about you though it just it there's I'm
gonna run and get how it could have been
just an acquaintance that lies got to
hold you and you're like what that's the
end of that I can't do much against that
oh well done like a lunch hike with a
with a guy who like trying to sign a
deal Inc it off and that giant grizzly
bears [ __ ] bro damn damn good luck you
I'm making your ass yeah run I'm gonna
get out of here
cuz no matter what no matter what you do
it with your kids your wife whatever you
would you would not my wife but my kids
I get Yaya honey you get this make it
easy on yourself give me your neck you
got me way quick if you just give me
that I'll raise the kids no no stop
defend your face he likes that no now I
got a dagger get back on the dating
scene
well I guess I'll download tinder now
cops like man we investigator you've
download it you downloaded [ __ ]
Grindr five minutes after your wife
passed the correct gate
yeah I know no I know a man though but
don't say that no I wouldn't know I well
I might you slid into some you sent a
dick pic in your DMS three minutes after
your wife died and we're getting a sex
change because my kids need a mother now
correct yeah yeah this is [ __ ] up
though that guy who got away your piece
of [ __ ] damn dude heat brother got
killed he's in heaven right now
no one got away the one running away got
killed right the one the one that took
off I was like being a town I love
coward meat and I smell a [ __ ] damn
that's tough though man if the whole
thing's a tragedy right it's a truck how
about how about was the other guy
injured I don't know if he's better now
he was in critical condition they saved
him he was just milk at 180 pounds oh my
god it's a huge cat no no so this one
was emaciated this one it's actually
starving oh that's why I attacked this
yeah so normally they're about 140 280
this one was a hundred pounds and I
thought this is a girl because this is
Sonia but I guess it's a guy how small
were these men do we know
no pictures I don't think they attack
you Brennan for real but there you go
after my son
I love out this cop just killed nothing
little surprises at the picture he's all
they got it though huh yeah you know how
I like to have like a hundred yards away
they found it in a tree really and then
they cuz obviously they're not [ __ ]
gloat amount line it's like going on the
body it's awful well they originally
when they when so that guy went to get
help right the guy who got up went to
get the cops came the Cougar was
standing over the dead man's body and
then ran away got up into the tree so he
was not there then to be cleared they go
we don't like kill him outline to make
sure strike one so they test the DNA in
the body the the muscle meat from even
guy's face off and I found out was him
Wow they said they see that no not this
one so that kid the Cougar had the guy's
head in its mouth entirely and it
dragged him to the den to the Cougars
den doc they're lions they are starving
so lions is starving
so they they kill elk so an elk is
stronger than you they kill you know
what they say to do though right mmm
they say get his Beach gimmick as most
know it do not run they say go towards
it and take your bike is like a shield
yeah okay said and most of they died but
they died don't run from it that's a
that's a that copper-oxide you don't
know what's going on in the picture you
know you don't know I'm lyin hey the cop
would bet head on the right hey bro
yeah they look high you know you know
Mountain look like hey man for a picture
yeah mal mining hear a peep out of wolf
right even though Timberwolf not a
[ __ ] laughing at a timber wolf how
about that you know that I don't want
but part of neither my mind kill a wolf
kill it laugh at it
cuz jump in jump apparently the length
of a school bus some outlines yeah watch
there's a shitload of them too and jump
the length of a school bus you hear that
crazy [ __ ] they wanted to create a path
over the 405 so they get over this way
yes sir
I'm off to vote on that right no huh
there's no II want to be wrong dying
gotta let him roam even one got hit on
the 405 gotta let him roam and they had
a picture of it you might want to take a
look at the picture that they have a
camera to picture that got that that
particular mountain lines a male and
take a look at the muscles on this bad
boy
now you look at a big strong dog like a
pit bull this is you know what a pit
bull coming at you this was the
Hollywood news on TNT he said some face
work done to his [ __ ] I think
it was it was on the 405 son
I saw its chest and I was like damn p90
it's got the ground with it thick thick
body man the mountain lion I'm 405
freeway there you go
you got well [ __ ] that's his tomb cross
thank you for that yeah dude look at
that thing OCP 55 that's what it is get
you in trouble Frank I'm trying to get
you educated and joining us right now to
do just that that lady like the national
park service everyone knows her as
Ranger Kate and we're looking at the
freeway you're doing Ranger Kate versity
and he mated multiple times
and so that's been a really positive
thing I'm Laura Kay inbred little things
cute baby for sure kill him due to the
grow up chances of finding a good mate a
female on the other side well if you can
stay out of the way of other males and
hopefully stay safe and not you know hit
on this Rangers glory a male a male will
kill a man I guess the males will kill
her the Cubs yeah hey thanks for nothing
hey [ __ ] is that mountain lion
Brentwood or not yeah I don't know man
don't mess with the mountain what else
you got chin this guy this lawyer
who's making the news yeah the rounds
and news because he has like so this is
a white lawyer that was going off on
spanish-speaking employees in a cafe in
New York because they're speaking
Spanish to each other he got pissed off
job he did loss his practice oh so you
guys saw him kind of like going you
country that's hot oh now it's gone he
probably took it down legally but have
you seen the previous ones that's the
thing so he found out that he was on
other videos like in this one and well
this is earlier in the month
what's wrong with him core you see
yelling ow in Spanish he's just he's he
seems pissed off yeah so he's saying
you're an [ __ ] [ __ ] you you're nice
people
yes another Jewish guys chew it you
saying you're not a Jew so what you
might call it here's a video here's
footage of him and this is in 2016
he's crazy so this guy this guy that
recorded it he's like a vlogger a
consultant and he's talking about this
meeting he had with some random dude on
his show at least he doesn't have hairy
arms he has terrible form that's him no
this is the guy who vlogs talking about
this guy two years earlier
I'll cut you from you I'm gonna call the
police you don't run into people I'm
gonna sit in here you're not you're an
ugly foreigner so what happened is that
vlogger was walking on the street and
they actually they're actually like near
the street where there's all this room
on the side for this is when it moved
wreck to move yeah the jerk lawyer just
came up closer to them and bumped them
and then he started saying what are you
where'd he like his application [ __ ] you
know what he needs a hassle he needs to
bump into the right person so they beat
the [ __ ] that he's a piece of [ __ ] who's
the hottest hair who's the hot girl with
that's it that's his girl with what the
vlogger your ugly cheap employer and
[ __ ] you he's a terrible guy
[Music]
look at how hot she is he's winning this
guy's winning here's a good-looking dude
so he needs to meet the right person
who's like what you say and then just
twist them and then what finally
happened to them is down his throat is
his life is jacked up now he's a lawyer
oh let me catch up with you baby yeah
but he'll find he'll have the
hatemongers on internet it will rally
around them he'll just have his own
community you know they sent a mariachi
band and a bunch of people to play
outside of his allotted building you're
not gonna win acting like that you never
know but he'll make he'll probably make
the weird thing about this business is
he'll make money cuz he'll have a bunch
of white supremists and and other people
who like him not New York not in New
York on New York or his practice is
screwed up now to know they get shut
down then
well his firm likes them out but that I
think he has like an office space -
that's cause he's such a [ __ ] - what a
[ __ ] he's a hateful dude people like
that do they need ramifications it's not
because he's a lawyer he just asked can
you get beat up by an image it yeah but
like a tough [ __ ] Mexican like you
need to do that to like a canal or oh
you know it'd be even better
sometimes Santa Monica you'll see some
of the cartel guys there and they're
Gucci stuff needs to bump into them and
talk like that to them see what happened
I'd pay money to watch that yeah yeah he
needs to he needs his ass kicked just
and Bryan's the one to do I would like
to let you paint your body like super
tan and then give them out like I'd like
when I see a guy like that I'd like to
punch him as hard as I can in the face
this crack is [ __ ] and break also
bloggers should have done it man you
want a fuse or not bro
it does make you really hate that guy
like that Oh make me this do two studs
sometimes it seems like six foot five
sometimes he's definitely stud I'll
sometimes oh he's not 65 or big yet so
sometimes no this guy this guy the
vlogger dude what the Xavier sometimes
I'll see stuff on the internet whether
it's a comet or things like this and it
bums me out for me and kind of like ah
[ __ ]
yeah man you get these really I think
there's something wrong with this guy
there's obviously something wrong with
his lot with his life though there's
something off like he's unhappy about
something you add ghetto act that way if
you're killing it in life yeah you know
like you don't send hateful tweets or
you don't troll someone if you're doing
well in life he has aim one troyler Matt
we're like [ __ ] man it's all emotional
it's like something happen to him it's
the anger in himself which makes him
lash out but it's weird because it
doesn't compute that wall in our heads
because he's a lawyer we hit we kind of
feel like if you're gonna get to that
point of being a lawyer you might have
made you just scuttles a Jewish and Jews
had to deal with that kind of [ __ ] for
their entire history they make sense
well then you'll not just that day to do
with being killed so he comes from a
group of people and a tradition of being
not only oppressed but killed by the
millions
so it's shocking to see a Jewish man
behave that way and also him that's not
impressed me just cuz he's a lawyer he
decided to study you know harder you're
focused on something else joy or is he
anyway no I just you figure he'd be he
wouldn't get to that point because he's
such an ass he's a practicing lawyer
means he passed the bar probably he's
not a very smart guy he looks like a
like a dumb he also he might be just a
bad dude right
he might just be a bad guy he's mad at
his life can work on something or maybe
his wife like [ __ ] the Mexican immigrant
yeah for real for real you're right that
is a good that's exactly right I think a
lot of times you can find it's like a
deep juicy some personal thing which why
you don't like someone or something or a
group there's something going on there
yes he sucks at life there's a wound
what else you got I just saw this Tyson
Fury saying that after boxing he wants
to become a doctor
cool certain necessary steps yeah do
that but I wish oh he's going to become
a doctor
good for him sure he's not gonna box
anymore one night when he's done he's
back to night I really want to see him
fight Anthony Joshua
he's about to his about two fights away
from it wow it's interesting him being a
doctor yeah be amazing what else you get
Jim let's see yeah oh let's show you
this one home we saw this earlier Leon
he's battling thyroid disorder
look how he looks right now Jim I mean
that's Julie now to me the hashtag no
racist prices some ages people age like
[ __ ] said this
like days like a fine wine and then some
age like fruit where it's like overnight
they just the the world catches up with
them some black people to white people
generally don't eat great you're the
exception but a lot don't age greater
but for Asians it's either you're wrong
with your thyroid man that's a real
honesty 5 years old 55 55 you're four
years younger yeah look at that
that'll break here man it's terrible
break yeah I mean he looks like about 55
[ __ ] starts happening by the way what
happened not to everybody if you're
lucky but you can get weird [ __ ] there's
some 55 year olds who are killing the
game there's some six year olds kill and
I'm hundred percent all right though man
that mess you up Wow um this one
Starbucks you don't have to buy anything
anymore to use the restroom
well they funds life yeah you can you
can go outside you get chill you find a
job that's a good idea
I don't think it's a good idea there I I
think they're like oh [ __ ] that racist
guy [ __ ] everything else so we're
saying out too and so now they're like
you can do whatever you want
it's gonna be a [ __ ] show I agree and
that's why you should buy bigger or is
it just add is watch buy big ground
coffee cuz we celebrate everywhere you
hang out anywhere you want is big brown
coffee come on finally June man we're
gonna have ourselves a little espresso
machine set up you know we're not
kicking anyone out no and we're gonna
have storefronts but I'm getting coffee
here it better be good coffee bro dude
that's me man you know I know you went
and did it tastes like coffee all right
anything else Jim that's that's terrible
although maybe maybe they went you know
most people are gonna buy they don't
like to hang out in a place where they
don't buy something so maybe the people
that are gonna come in there and hang
out are gonna do it anyway and have been
doing it anyway that's no thank you
it's them trying to save face still can
reserve the right to kick you out I
would imagine if you're being a jerk or
something probably but if you're just a
bum did I tell you what
listen bums matter to right but if
you're in a store and there's two bums
sitting in the recliners and you're
there with your kid and they smell like
[ __ ] and they're talking crazy
you're not gonna it's gonna be bad
business I'm not one of these guys who
says you know III just think
I think they [ __ ] should I be allowed to
just come into any private establishment
I think they're supposed to be like you
smell bad you're crazy you're not
allowed in my store I'm sorry I'm also
you can't go sit down nice but it's not
a business of you if you're a life you
have to let everybody in yeah when you
come into a restaurant you have no shirt
on they go you got to put a shirt on
there's certain standards so then it's
in that's it your back be you were
you're out of body last Friday I know
you're little tired there's the worst
podcast we've never dabbed I forgive you
thank you because your goat story made
sense this time well this was a real
goat story but you put your dick on my
back which I don't appreciate because
that's what I did to the goat no wonder
you got freaked out I know where she I
know
go plug does that to me when I get it on
my face and just get I start speaking in
tongues let me hear you do the let me
hear you do the coat again the dying
goat now now is there a difference
between a dying goat or and the one
calling for its baby what's the one
calling for its baby yeah oh that's good
sense of urgency okay that's a sense of
urgency that's higher yeah and what's
the dying one again and as I'm cutting
his throat can I hear that yeah yeah
that's exactly what it sounded like
that's what it sounded like
yeah I'm sorry to all you vegans out
there but that's what happened and I
dashed I when I - the baby with vegans
do you drink water
yeah that's plant food that's right dude
if you drink water you're taking 14
plants yeah think about it think about
back in haters think about that sit on
that dick I just gotta sit on that
celery dick
I got that's not the historical record
he goes yeah what's history his story we
can they find you be printed I'm glad
you asked now this Thursday this coming
Thursday is it this coming though it's
next Thursday the 31st of May that's
next next yeah may 31st June 1 June to
get your [ __ ] tickets house of Comedy
Bloomington Minnesota oh I was cause
then I'm coming hard do come and tell
them to make a Cinnabon like I did
I eat myself with cinnamon never had a
cent amount of my life but I'm gonna
videotape myself eating Cinnabon and
then crashing well that and your strides
you can break out bro can you eat can
you eat lunch tonight I sure can
got it you said breakfast then he said
lunch tonight I did oh good ah um do are
you in town on the 16th June uh I don't
know we'll figure it out I'm at the ice
house with friends surprise guests June
16
I thought ice I'm south ice house
Pasadena one show only that [ __ ] is
almost sold out one show Saturday night
Pasadena ice house tea fat kada come for
tickets for Bryan myself and then June
22nd through the 23rd Houston improv she
shows Friday to show Saturday get
tickets now Brian and myself we got a
special clap coming out next month with
roots of 5 sides for this yeah super
excited see we don't you haven't seen it
boy I'm sure to you though yes yes
all right you love you guys cheering
does the fire kid Wow